io ogni quando parla mi chiedo non vuoi
usare il power point e e dico che ppt
per me vuol dire per piacere togliete
meli perché se funzionano la vostra
attenzione giustamente su quello che
facevamo vedere così queste sono le onde
gravitazionali certi e se non quindi se
funzionano guardatele il sullo schermo
se non funzionano succede un po quello
che succede
meglio non averli allora io posso usarlo
sa bene che un uomo parlare in pubblico
muoversi c'è un maschio intendo dire e
fa e schiacciare questo pulsante sono
tre cose insieme gli uomini tre cose
insieme quindi c'è qualcuno sotto i 20
anni duranti n perfetto allora tu lo
prendi devi schiacciare il tasto
scherson capace però si sa ma la devi
schiacciare da tenere quando ti guardo
no quello è quello da destra aspetta
quando te lo dico io per esempio
proviamo prova schiacciare grande sta lì
adesso perfetto allora il la scelta non
è dovuta
cara maria pia alla partita dell'inter
di ieri in cui la mia squadra vestita
come delle lattine di sprite se qualcuno
l'ha vista vuoti a perdere e non è
dovuta al fatto che ieri sera alle otto
e mezza non in televisione e abbiamo
parlato della giunta di roma e dell di
virginia raggio di quello che sto
venendo a roma che sarebbe un altro
insomma perfettamente inter no non
c'entra questo no io ho scelto questo
titolo perché credo che nel rinnovamento
capire il fallimento è un modo di
parlare del successo sono sicuro che
l'avete capito e noi abbiamo un qualche
modo una sorta di tabù sul fallimento
con la ragazza di una di una radio di
matera marie qui se non è scappata mi ha
chiesto a stato che si usa sempre meno
l'espressione sbagliando si impara
ed è vero sbagliando si impara una di
quelle frasi che ci ricevono da ragazzi
quindi
non puoi sapere ma io sì e in italiano
abbiamo anche eliminato un'espressione
abbiamo paura perfino le parole sono
molto in distruttive della parola
fallimento in inglese ai feolde vuol
dire c'è sottointeso ci ho provato
sottinteso ma non è andata bene non ce
l'ho fatta
in italia abbiamo paura dell'espressione
ho fallito pochissimi usano
l'espressione ho fallito perché al
participio passato assomiglia troppo al
predicato nominale di io sono un fallito
il fallimento per chi ha studiato la
materia è anche giuridicamente è un è
una è un è un segno che rimane sulle
persone in maniera drammatica
in italia abbiamo dei problemi col
fallimento io non voglio fare nessuna o
del fallimento anche se devo dire agli
stati uniti che hanno tanti problemi io
spero che uno grosso a novembre non ce
lo scaricano addosso a noi ma devo
ammettere che hanno un gusto del dl
provarci e dall'accettare che se uno
ripeto cia fallisce se non altro ci ha
provato in qualche modo sono sempre
disposti a rischiare la sconfitta per
vincere noi troppo spesso in tutti i
nostri mestieri i nostri atteggiamenti
firmiamo subito per il pareggio problema
però non ho nessuna intenzione di farvi
l'apologia del fallimento io sono
convinto che sia meglio non fallire
ma se proprio uno vuole fallire come non
l'ho mai fatto prima mi sono preso due
appunti per seguire
credo che ci sia proprio una ricetta per
il fallimento e mi sono segnato 5 punti
allora ci sono cinque cose da fare se mi
seguite con attenzione potrete sa potete
stare certi che qualsiasi cosa provate
sarà un disastro
punto 1 vai improvvisate voi dite ma
l'improvvisazione una cosa bellissima
attenzione le idee arrivano
improvvisamente queste spettacolari e
vengono improvvisamente quando la nostra
mente non è completamente occupata da
preoccupazioni vengono il dormiveglia
vengono sugli aeroplani quando ci fanno
spegnere il telefono vengono in bagno il
bagno e una grandissima fonte di
ispirazione bisognerebbe quando mi
dicono beppe ti ngo i tuoi libri in
bagno vorrei baciarli è un grande
complimento
prima al bagno poi la biblioteca le idee
vengono improvvisamente ci sono potrete
nervi qua tutta la sera ma so che i
tempi sono stretti dobbiamo andare
veloci buzzati dino buzzati un autore
che mi ha molto chiaro scritto una cosa
bellissima dice cos'è l'ispirazione
cos'è
e lui ha detto è uno straniero che
arriva improvvisamente a visitarmi non è
un è 1 st è una persona che non conosco
dice la lava personalizzata e ci sono
c'è tutto un momento pre creativo che
chiunque armin penso di mestiere in
tutte le professioni esiste ma questa è
un'altra cosa non è
le idee arrivano improvvisamente ma le
idee poi quando hai avuto un'idea ma ci
devo dormire sopra grande saggezza
molte delle idee che ci vengono in
maniera improvvisa esaminate con
attenzione si rivelano una sciocchezza
ma alcune sono le idee io invito tutti a
segnarci su un taccuino ea portarsi in
tasca 8 pt possono cambiare la vita
io la mia moglie molto gelosa no quando
sono fuori a cena con una giovane
collega ma quando sono fuori a cena da
solo mia moglie l'ha perché quando sono
a cena da solo ogni tanto mi piace molto
mi metto lì e mi rendo conto che
moltissime idee c'è ancora da tutti quei
taccuini vengono nei momenti in cui ti
puoi staccare e ma questo non vuol dire
improvvisare l'improvvisa intuizione non
è l'ispirazione è improvvisa intuizione
ma poi occorre trasformare aggiungere
che la vera qualità e l'immaginazione
organizzata noi possediamo come
carattere nazionale
amat ero a milano amante o a marsala e
perfino nelle città che non cominciano
per m
noi possediamo in italia una capacità di
fantasia che noi vediamo la che non è
una barzelletta la crescita forse perché
finiamo a bagnomaria nella bellezza e
veniamo da storie quelle città come
queste ce l'abbiamo noi abbiamo quindi è
molto facile per noi lui l'ha raccontato
molto bene prima quando raccontato
un iraniano americano che viene in
italia ne capisce la bellezza e i
meccanismi dentro la bellezza però
attenzione abbiamo un problema che
qualche volta attendiamo improvvisare
pensiamo che la nostra improvvisa
intuizione sia sufficiente non è
sufficiente occorre quello che gli
inglesi chiamano bouaghi uno dei grandi
direttori del cono e miss volte budget
sito budget ben diceva per spiegare il
successo grande dell'inghilterra
vittoriana imperiale diceva dal nancy
sawan line clever nel sisal line del
french la nostra specialità e quasi noi
lui non dico l'ottusità ma la
prevedibilità l'intelligenza ma ciò è
vanessa ha usato non è la specialità dei
francesi voleva dire che che gli inglesi
sapevano unire che che occorre una
regola il tutti gli italiani che hanno
successo del mondo non improvvisano
uniscono alla fantasia al genio
all'intuizione all'idea improvvisa la
capacità di revisionare di ragionare su
quello che hanno fatto
e questi italiani spaccano gli altri no
diamo due illudetevi la creatività
consente il bluff
la creatività consente di bluffare con
noi stessi anche con gli altri
esattamente come la seduzione l'arte
moderna e a differenza del nuoto del
tango e del biliardo che non consentono
seduzione bluff quelle invece la
creatività consente alla seduta ma non
soltanto ingannare gli alti ma anche
ingannare noi stessi
uno dei veri problemi dell'essere una
ricetta per il fallimento il punto 2
dell'ingrediente è l'illusione impartì
una forma particolare di illusione che
sono le interferenze dalla passione non
siamo più capaci di giudicare il nostro
talento perché è una cosa ci piace così
tanto che vogliamo farla tutti i costi
potrei raccontarvi non so se so scrivere
forse un pochino sì io vi assicuro che
l'estetica ma non leggi
mi manda 400 pagine ne leggo 10 di con
mio dio e lui dicano no guardi deve
leggere le altre 390 anche no perché è
un allenatore di calcio capisce dopo due
tocchi e se giocare a pallone un
violinista ho visto passare i violini io
sono di crema provincia di cremona suoni
cinque minuti e sa se io non devo poter
capire in dieci pagine
se tu sai che pacchia si no perché la
scrittura consente le illusioni uno
vuole scrivere una grande passione per
scrivere e cosa fa
si illude di poter scrivere le
interferenze della passione sono
estremamente pericolose un'altra cosa
importante e ignorate le possibili
enormi possibilità che le nuove che le
nuove che i nuovi strumenti consentono
di giudicare noi stessi sono più chiaro
i social network e mi fanno molto
arrabbiare
io adesso so che quando chiuderò
guarderò twitter uno mitra ieri dopo
dopo otto e mezzo meran dette di tutti i
colori ogni volta che vado in
televisione
capita è però io ritengo che faccia
parte del gioco se non superi i confini
del lei del dl del codice penale va bene
se ho voluto giocare a questo gioco
915 mila non lo so follower su twitter
ce ne saranno dieci chili altri un po
meno fa niente allora il punto è questo
qua che molte di queste persone sono
utili tutto quello che facciamo può
essere testato a oggi come non poteva
essere testato prima un giornalista
io ho conosciuto colleghi che hanno
creduto per 25 anni di essere sale della
terra perché l'ex direttore il collega
di scrivania gli dicevo che ora scritto
delle cose bellissime
in effetti ero gli unici due lettori
queste illusioni non sono più consentite
sulle cose che facciamo quindi illudersi
è la ii è ingrediente della ricetta del
fallimento vai poi ti regalo un libro
irrigiditevi forzate forzate le idee non
aspettate che arrivi non aspettate di
come dicevo prima il momento bellissimo
dell'ispirazione che vi aria forzata e
fatevi venire idee per forza una società
di consulenza non so se sia vero ma è
una cifra affascinante sostiene che nel
1970 ognuno di noi aveva circa 700 800
informazioni al giorno che gli
arrivavano adesso è ben in cui se mi
interessa adesso sono circa 30mila noi
siamo bombardati informazione di tutti i
tipi
vuol dire che ne siamo estremamente
occupati quindi la forzatura è già un
altro modo per avvicinarsi al fallimento
volete sapere un altro modo interessante
di irrigidirsi e mi sembra perfetto
visto quello che ha ascoltato prima
irrigiditevi nei vostri luoghi di lavoro
in una classica distinzione del mondo
del lavoro in italia ma non soltanto in
italia quella fra esecutori e inventori
è una sciocchezza è una vera sciocchezza
io e più grosse le più grosse
ci sono dei muratori in italia che sono
dei veri artisti e ci sono alcuni
architetti che avrebbero molti problemi
a mettere due bottoni uno sull'altro
io ho capito che è parte di questo gioco
it ed è anche mettersi immettersi e
raccontare alle non ho nessuna
difficoltà a dirlo io ho condotto un
programma televisivo io ho una delle
discussioni che ha avuto è stato di
spiegare che ci agli autori sono i
creativi i redattori sono gli esecutori
quelli che fanno gli avevo otto ragazzi
che erano i più bravi d'italia che avevo
trovato che ho avuto la fortuna in
questo devo ringraziare la rai che mara
con di chiamarli a lavorare un anno con
meno venivano da tutta italia erano
spaccavano questi erano i redattori
avevo dei bravi autori e c'era da
preparare il programma di israele una
delle mie ragazze
era una ragazza che ha vissuto in
israele stava per tornare in israele e
doveva discutere per unire le riunioni
ma non è un'autrice ma chi se ne frega
e così via allora la distinzione fra
autori
ed esecutori tra inventori ed esecutori
è un vero problema
se avete dei dubbi io vi consiglio un
bellissimo libro che la chiave a stella
di primo levi e voi vedete che nelle
mani di un artigiano italiano c'è tanta
poesia
c'è tanto genio c'è tanto e non bisogna
rispettarla soltanto così nelle chi ha
bisogno perché se voi accettate l'idea
che ogni bravo esecutore anche un
inventore e ogni buon inventore sa anche
fare le cose immaginarle siete a buon
punto
4 siate timorosi io credo che essere
troppo timorosi sia un altro modo di
avvicinarsi al fallimento molte delle
nostre cose più belle che abbiamo fatto
sul lavoro vengono da un atto di
incoscienza ho sentito prima una
bellissima apologia della maternità
avere un figlio è un atto di incoscienza
se uno ci pensano la più figli per
fortuna il mondo va avanti perchè c'è un
atto di incoscienza quando devi prendere
un lavoro e non sai sia giusto la vita
va avanti per atti di incoscienza tutte
le persone che hanno combinato qualcosa
da una bella famiglia fino a un
capolavoro hanno cominciato con un
piccolo attori che lo vuol dire
responsabilità vuol dire incoscienza
ai ragazzi dico volete fallire venite a
proponetevi nel lavoro offrendo sempre
solo la vostra buona volontà la vostra
buona volontà si da per scontata voi
dovete portare delle idee
dovete portare la vostra fantasia perché
noi soprattutto coi capelli bianchi
senza io parlo dei maschi ed i capelli
bianchi senza capelli coi capelli
colorati sono tutte le categorie
ne abbiamo molto bisogno quindi la di il
timore qualche volta è il modo di
fallire e pensare essere troppo timorosi
quando ti offro io ti proponi non
spacciati ma essere timorosi e un errore
un altro modo di essere timorosi avere
paura di copiare copiate ma con
intelligenza e garbo possibilmente ogni
ogni atto creativo e artistico è
una forma di furto basta citare il
derubato ogni tanto che anche cortese
c'era einstein sentito citare più spesso
e diceva che di fatto la creatività e è
coprire bene proprie fonti però è lo
riceva uno insomma però in buona
sostanza e non abbiate paura quando io
sento dire che qualcuno può scrivere non
legge io leggo tantissimi romanzi lengo
anche poesie non ne scrivo però mi ha
aiutato tantissimo scrivere ho fatto
anche l'attore teatrale e mi aiuta
stasera vi assicuro quando voi sentite
un musicista che non ascolta musica
sareste sbalorditi così come con un
cuoco inappetente succede ci sono
persone ed è una forma estrema di
arroganza non volere ascoltare imitare
stavo scherzando chi non vuol dire
copiare plagiare e nascondere però vuol
dire che tutto quello che si fa in tutti
i campi la scienza del cern o se come
dice lui noi siamo cern e in italia il
del cern all archeologia o tutti i campi
che avete ascoltati oggi di fatto
vengono sulle spalle di quelli che è
arrivato prima qualche volta sono dei
giganti sulle spalle dei nanerottoli più
spesso siamo dai nanerottoli sulle
spalle dei giganti ma un giornalista
scrittore che non legge che uno studia
con amore i buzzati e montanelli che è
stato il mio maestro
il flaiano e i soldati ei longanesi ai
bardini un pazzo e io ai ragazzi siccome
un'età in cui mi tocca farlo li prendo
gli spiego che devono fare che devono
imparare e leggere questo è copiare
copiare gli stilemi copiare i ritmi e
imparare al si impara a scrivere
leggendo si impara a fare i cuochi
mangiando punto 5 siamo in chiusura
ho visto il tempo ancora un minuto e
mezzo isolatevi io ho scelto un'immagine
poetica ma l'isolamento questo e poetico
ma in genere l'isolamento non è poetico
io vorrei chiudere su questo punto io
credo che mescolare talenti e
generazione la cosa più bella chi si può
fare steve jobs che che di tutto si può
dire steve jobs a parte il fatto che lui
di tasse non
occupate quindi quella è la parte di
apple che mi sta simpatica quest'altra
un po meno e steve jobs nei suoi gruppi
di lavoro voleva un laureato in scienze
naturali voleva un laureato in materie
umanistiche voleva un giurista non più
di uno per carità ma voleva un lo era
uno che venisse della losco e poi
ovviamente voleva il computer santis ma
li voleva tutti insieme perché capiva
che da tutte queste cose che
l'intelligenza non è iq e capacità di
prendere un problema e risolverlo e
lavorare tutti insieme allora mescolare
il talenti ve l'ho detto mescolare le
generazioni ci ho fatto uno spettacolo
teatrale non lo faccio più ho girato
l'italia 50 tappe è la storia di un
signore la mia età bloccata con una
ragazza di 28 anni due litigano mary
pazzi all'inizio alla fine capiscono che
possono aiutarci lui prima e
paternalista e poi a paterno che è un
passaggio secondo me è molto bello e a
un certo punto dice lei dice ma se il
mio capo mi dice stai zitta perché ai 28
anni non capisce un cazzo gli dico che
fortuna che hai il tuo capo ti sta
dicendo di essere un deficiente
allontanati appena possibile da un uomo
del genere perché un uomo della mia età
un uomo vecchia un capo di qualsiasi
tipo in un reparto ospedaliero è
un'azienda e un giornale dovunque si ha
la fortuna di avere un ragazzo una
ragazza comunità comincia per due che
lavora con lui e benedetto è una
benedizione perché è un ragazzo che ha
un'età pe comincia per due quindi tu fra
tre anni adesso è un po presto
puoi portare la fantasia l'incoscienza
il coraggio e tu mio coetaneo puoi
portare l'esperienza magari la capacità
di sintesi sono un'alleanza naturale che
hanno portato un sacco di cose belle e
noi dobbiamo veramente a smettere in
questo paese io ci litigo un giorno sì e
l'altro pure con persone che mi dicono
che ragazzi e ragazze di 28 tu sei un po
giovane ho sentito il vagito devi
aspettare un attimo ma per il resto
per il resto vi assicuro che a 30 anni
si sia 28 anni ha 27 anni si è pronti
per quasi tutto soprattutto se si è ben
guidati soprattutto chiudo con questo
isolatevi vuol dire evitate non
accettate di essere incoraggiati e non
smette e non incoraggiate
l'incoraggiamento è una star strada a
doppio senso se io incoraggio un ragazzo
e una ragazza lui senza col suo lavoro e
con me mi guarda e com'è che in quel
momento lui incoraggia a me e
l'incoraggiamento e la cosa più bella ed
è la ricetta l'antidoto al fallimento e
la capacità di essere incoraggiato e
l'umiltà del pd incorna scusate il
coraggio di incoraggiare e l'umiltà di
essere incoraggiate le persone generose
non falliscono mai io vi assicuro
volevo chiudere con pensate questo con
una un'immagine epica sapete cos'è il
gesto di etero è diventato anche un
titolo di un bellissimo film hector e
nelle li ed e a un certo punto prende il
bambino si avvicina a suo figlio
astianatte e lui sa tutto pensato un
guerriero ritocchi e fisico dove avere
altro che le palestre di oggi con tutte
e aveva tutto questo elmo e il bambino è
terrorizzata da questo padre sporco
forse di terra di sangue questo è e
comincia a urlare lui capisce si eleva
l'elmo lo mette giù il figlio lo
riconosce lo prende lo alza e dice una
cosa bellissima che nell epica non aveva
mai detto nessuno dice dei fate in modo
che questo bambino sia più forte di me e
un giorno lo vedo né di kone è questo è
molto più forte di suo padre ettore e
questa cosa nelip che non avrà detto mai
nessuno ha è stato ucciso ma ettore ha
vinto non ha fallito
achille infondere un uomo solo grazie
[Applauso]